[Music]
a couple years ago i worked on a movie
with great crew small crew in new york
and the camera operator was a filipino
descent and i loved talking to him about
his culture his family he was very
adamant that i would love filipino food
based on what he knew about me and i had
never had filipino food though and one
day
he brought some for me to sample it was
really kind of him and i had been so uh
excited about the prospect of trying it
and he opened the thing there's a little
container that he had made inside was
this very uh gelatinous looking
mound of uh and he said and he had been
calling it the filipino name
but really what it was was like pork fat
it was like almost complete
completely fat and i'm much more
squeamish than that we didn't grow up
eating that kind of food did you eat it
i did and the first few bites were like
you know just because of the texture and
and once i
overcame that
it i gotta say it was delicious
i hate saying that because i want to eat
less i don't want to eat as much meat
and especially pigs we talk about that
actually um
but well there's a lesson in there what
is it i don't know it feels like there's
a lesson in that
i thought you knew
eat your fat well
let's chew on that fat and yeah let's
chew on it okay about it
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short uh i'm
your host justin long life could be a
dream
[Music]
you also vaguely resemble with me as
always a filipino man i would say
i would say of all the asian
countries you may resemble i've
you know who i get a lot is um manny
pacquiao yeah which is a lot you don't
get a lot uh around the time mostly in
your mostly your body yeah my skill my
fighting skills no around the time i
grew uh every once in a while i'll
attempt to grow facial hair and um
when i grow a goatee i'd go tea for
something you do have yeah
yeah
for sure yes yeah because he has i mean
he's obviously very impressive in many
ways but the ability to grow facial hair
is not one of those
things that one of the things that's
impressive about him it's quite
unimpressive right but just looking at
you i would assume you might like
filipino food only because i mean of
course if i didn't know you i would
assume you might be part filipino yeah
maybe that's maybe that was subconscious
but in in
i disguised defense uh great guy too i
i like talking to the crew you know it
was a small
it was one of those small shoots so like
you spent a lot of time with each other
and it's not like you're going back to
your trailer and stuff so i like talking
to him about and i like food and he was
a good he liked talking about food i
like filipino people so you've never had
filipino food i don't think so i may
have well still remember and what's it
like it's like
something it's very
meat based i mean like they eat a lot of
meat but how does it compare to say uh
like vietnamese food you know what it's
kind of like uh i i bet remember when
you had that special far well what was
in it like entrails and stuff like
everything everything like every part of
uh i tried animal i couldn't get past
that stuff because it's just it's a
psychological barrier with that stuff
once you get past it
and the texture sometimes that well the
flavor is
well chirasha is incredible i don't i
hope there are um squeamish vegans
vegans i know i know we should be
talking about that maybe not because the
truth is and i mean this i really do
want to eat less eventually no from my
point of view you've been eating less
meat yeah yeah than in the past no i
know i'm not i'm
like that's sincere so why are we
talking about we are talking about the
philippines because our guest today well
he's half filipino our guest today is
dave bautista he's a lot more than a
half filipino person much more he is
also half greek
no he's that's pretty much it yeah well
there's that's the episode you've been
listening to uh he is he's a renaissance
man he was a huge wrestler i and chris
and i are not uh you know both have to
not be into wrestling but we're not that
into wrestling uh so i didn't this is
how big he was in the wrestling world
that uh despite our lack of knowledge
right i was like i still knew who that's
true there are very few there's a
handful of wrestlers that are
so famous in the wrestling world who
else would you say that about uh i would
say chris jericho i knew who he was um
hulk hogan of course people like that
well yeah
yeah but like those
john cena well now
i see in a modern era i don't know if
like oh the
miz but see though they've all
transitioned oh i know ric flair
yeah ric flair uh yeah so anyway point
is he was a very famous wrestler okay
and now he's a very famous actor
uh mostly known for guardians the galaxy
and the uh
mcu
and uh the mancrush universe yes but now
he's also doing he's branching out as an
actor uh we'll get into it we'll get
into a lot because he i i just find him
so fascinating i got to meet him briefly
uh through a mutual friend john down in
tampa
and um he just could not have been a
sweeter person and and really
interesting uh surprisingly interesting
and um defied a lot of stereotypes that
i had about somebody like dave well i
can't wait to hear it all right you're
about to here it is my uh my catch up
with
my friend my largest friend you don't
have to brag that he's large or he's my
but he's your friend
i do because it's i still have that
little uh you know that movie my
bodyguard i'm still i still have a
little chris make piece in me where i
need a um
and i haven't heard that name in a while
oh no he was a great child actor um but
yeah i like that i have a big friend i
get it yeah okay so
anyway uh i catch up with my big friend
big hearted friend too what a kind
person
and very funny and very very interesting
dave bautista
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
why do i think you've been a dj were you
ever a dj no no no i was uh so i worked
in nightclubs for about 13 years but
that's right surprise surprise i was a
bouncer
you must have been much bigger back then
i actually was about 100 pounds heavier
what yeah you were oh my god yeah i was
a meathead well i was more of a meathead
where does 100 pounds go on you
everywhere i was evenly distributed i
was a massive human being because at one
point i thought that my
path in life was going to going to be a
professional bodybuilder and i thought i
was going to be a professional
bodybuilder yeah so that's all i did i
worked nights i worked out twice a day
and i just i
ate and lifted and that's all i did that
was my life oh my god dave i've always
wondered about people who pursue that is
it and this might be like an obvious
answer but did you enjoy the process of
that i mean did you just enjoy working
out and is that fun
like how does that feel so the thing was
back then i didn't really i didn't
really know what direction to go with it
i just knew that i loved working out and
i didn't really know why i loved working
out so much i didn't realize why i was
so obsessed with it i found out found
out later in life why is that do you
think because i'm [ __ ] up
okay
so this is therapy for me i i tell you
that's where i get all my anxiety all my
aggression oh my
bad mojo out and i joke but it's it's
half a joke but i think that if i didn't
have that outlet i probably would have
killed someone
years ago wow
and would this be what would be the most
likely of uh scenario that that would
have happened would it be as as a
bouncer would it be in the ring would it
be it would have been later in my
teenage years no later in my two years
teen years um
sort of my early 20s when i was bouncing
i was just
i was very misguided i was a product of
my environment i was surrounded by the
worst people man and you know the 90s
and dc was just it was just really rough
like it was just really rough you're
such a recognizable person you you are
so
unique looking i mean you're uh as you
said massive and um for people who
haven't met you it's really like in
person you're just
it's crazy how tall how big are you i'm
uh i'm
six four about 275 five pounds
so i'm sure people already are like whoa
that that dude's big
and then they see that it's you
and
uh they identify you by one of your
specific
tattoos um
how how do you
how do you handle that kind of thing
well i live in tampa for one
and uh you've seen my life you know my
life it's very low-key it's very normal
i have a very small circle of friends
it's a small circle of huge friends
that would be that would be a fairer
that would be a fairy tale yeah they're
all messed up they're like they're yours
yeah most of my yeah most of my dudes
are like yeah they're like meatheads
we're kind of into the same stuff um
it's funny you keep using that word
meathead and my association this is why
i love doing the show one of the reasons
i my association with the word meathead
having been a you know a nerdier guy
in high school meathead to me was always
um synonymous with yeah working out and
being big but also they were the guys
who were kind of dumb who were like just
into sports and like and i've met your
friends they're they're they're not like
that at all they're really like sweet
like intelligent people right so it's
interesting to me that i i have to break
my association with the word media well
i think we use i think we use it a lot
and you're right man some of the guys
like i have a
so my uh personal assistant is uh is
massive and the guy who actually i i
opened my gym for his name's joe bennett
one of the smartest guys like he's
he's like the workout rain man he's just
a genius yeah the way this guy is just
so far over my head but he's he's huge
but i think it's a self-deprecating
thing we use it as a joke it's any i
wouldn't get mad if somebody else gave
me a meat head i did this is funny i
this goes a long way back but it's
popping into my head now but i was on a
plane and i was trying to get my
carry-on into the overhead bin
and i could hear this woman i would love
to see i could hear this woman behind me
getting super frustrated i'm looking at
her and i'm doing my best and i finally
get in and i sit down and she walks by
me and she goes all bra no brain
and i sat there oh my god i was like wow
and i just it hurt my feelings so bad
i walked back to her and i said excuse
me you are a rude woman and she said
excuse me i said you heard me you are a
rude woman unbelievable and i just
walked back to my seat
and that was like the best i had you're
rude
she came up to me when we got off the
plane and she apologized she said i just
no
just having a bad day and i was like i
totally get it but that like that things
like that offend me because don't look
at me and make that assumption that i'm
a [ __ ] [ __ ] just because i'm a large
person i am a large person for for a
reason it's really a side effect of my
mental issues
yes
yeah you probably have an insecurity
that people
or at least the perception that people
think that of you
uh just based on on
you know stereotypes and stuff but but
you probably so rarely hear it voice you
know because i would imagine most the
people who encounter you even the ones
who may think that
aren't going to have the balls to say it
anywhere in your
vicinity yeah yeah i hope that and i you
know
i've grown wise in my old age i always
take you know if i if someone insults me
i always look at where the insult is
coming from who it's coming from
and kind of yeah gauge it from that
but uh yeah back in my hand which is
something i was unable to do like in my
early 20s if you and so likewise we're
fighting
that's right yeah
again like i can't imagine unless it's
somebody in a frustrated passenger on a
plane and just slips out i can't imagine
people doing it i can't imagine
confronting you in that way
uh certain certainly when your
your job is to be a bouncer yes to
control who's coming in and out of an
environment i can't imagine
i'm sure you got
provoked or you got into entanglements
with a lot of like they were probably
mostly drunk
yeah i got people who would i did i you
know i went stepping i went to jail a
few times when i was
when i was bouncing and just because
things would get out of hand i would get
into fights over stupid stuff and
usually with somebody who was drunk
but um
i you know what you you know i take
like i take pride in being the police
guy in the room i would like to be the
place guy in the room and be the nicest
guy in the room and i would absolutely
take pride in that i think there's just
like i don't need to intimidate anybody
it doesn't make me feel good to
intimidate anybody and i don't
understand
that bully mentality it makes no sense
to me it never did and i will never be
that guy would be ashamed of myself if i
was that guy it's weird i think some
people like they get into weightlifting
or they get into martial arts they get
into it for different reasons i think i
got into it
i think i got into it because it was
just like i said it was my outlet and
there were you know i joke about to say
that i've got mental issues but you know
it's just because you know from when i
was young i just i saw things that a lot
of kids shouldn't see i i went through
things that dealt with things that a lot
of kids shouldn't you know
shouldn't have to yeah i want to hear
your story because
when i met you i
you know we just it wasn't the occasion
to talk about it i remember thinking oh
i hope dave comes on the podcast because
i really
you mentioned a few things but i would
love to hear it um how how you how it
all started
my life for
yeah i mean i i want to know conception
yeah i want to know the exact uh details
of your concern
the song that was playing no you you're
i know you're very close with your mom
you mentioned you grew up outside dc
yeah uh what what did your parents do my
mom's greek my dad's filipino and so
which may not think sound like an odd
combination now
but back then like you know 50s 60s it
was not you know completely acceptable
yeah yeah so anyway but
my parents actually split up when i was
very young um
for the most part because my mom is a
lesbian so
that'll
that'll have should have something to do
with it but she was
she was but but i'm sure you're
oversimplified but like when because you
had mentioned that to me as well and
when did she know that i mean you now
you you told me that yeah it's
unmistakable but how what was that
process like for her she always knew she
said she always knew um so it was just
you know it's one of those things she
went you know through high school my dad
and her dated she was they were high
school sweethearts it was never any
flaming romantic relationship but they
were
yeah you know they were to get together
long enough and to have me and my sister
and until she [ __ ] rolled out and she
she moved to san francisco and we
followed and you know i didn't grow up
with a father he never really took part
in my life although he was there and i
knew who he was and where he was and i
lived with him for a brief time you know
when i was younger but never really took
an interest in me
well daddy issues for sure you know but
uh at what point in your life did you
become aware of oh well this is why
mommy left and this is how she feels
about what her sexuality is like
when did that start to gel for you
it kind of all blends together like i
never seem like an odd thing to me
and i get asked about it all the time
did it seem odd and it just never did i
don't remember being a kid and
and have and and other kids you know
teasing me about it or anything like
that i just really i don't remember
thinking that it was odd that my mother
was with women and my mother always had
girlfriends and she never hit who she
was
well this was in san francisco so could
it could it be that the other kids were
also i mean for sure
it was that environment was very
progressive
yeah yeah i'm sure that had a lot to do
with it like everybody's mom was a
lesbian you know
yeah yeah be weird if your parents were
straight
ooh weirdo
yeah whoa wait a minute
a woman and a man
yeah that's funny so and your sister
would travel with you she would go back
and forth yes
for the most part she what she did i
think
like when i went back to live with my
dad when i was uh just getting out of
control i think i was 12 or 13.
my sister stayed with my mom and that
was actually when my sister and i became
very estranged we
we don't really speak much anymore we
just went we took different paths
like i was 12 13 years old getting
arrested like and my mom was coming to
get me out of jail
and i was wow for what kind of stuff um
fighting stealing you know yeah i was
that age and i was on the streets yeah
just stupid stuff vandalism yeah
anything stupid that you know kids do
for your age were you a big kid for yeah
12 year old well that was the thing i
was you know i was bigger than my mom
went by that time
and i you know i was bigger than my mom
and i was starting to act up and i was
surrounded by knuckleheads and so my mom
just got to the point where she was
like she was beating my ass every week
and that wasn't working
i just can't do that because she really
she thought she's like i'm not strong
enough to be disastrous
actually i think she was just more
afraid i threw i really think that my
mom thought that i was going to end up
dead
and which you know was not far-fetched
at that time so she sent me back to my
dad and then i was a culture shock
because i went from living
in the inner city of san francisco to
you know hanging out with gangs not
going to school
you know hanging out all all night till
you know i'd sneak out at night seeing
out when my mom went to sleep we just
i'd stay up to like four or five come
home wow sleep update oh my god but so
anyway as a 12 year old yeah man i was
that was a mess
wow were you hanging out with older kids
oh yeah older kid but you know then the
older kids were like 15 16 but teenagers
yeah are you familiar with san francisco
at all a little bit i mean i know the
like kind of shishi tour i know i've
been to haiti and like castro i know the
castro district yeah we lived uh right
now i think 14th or 16th in castro when
i was like in the early 70s like the
harvey milk era like i remember all that
yeah my mom was so she was such an
activist and she for years really
unbelievable what what what are your
memories of that uh living there
i have you know a few good memories and
i have a few bad memories i remember
seeing my first pride parade it must
have been like in the 70s and not really
knowing what it was it was just another
parade for me but it was like crazy you
know yeah i remember like you're really
just a bunch of parents
i remember like there was well san
francisco pride is something special
but i remember just thinking it was just
it was just a parade but i also remember
like i remember when i was young and we
were walking through chinatown and a
bunch of kids threw some firecrackers in
my mom's hair and started calling her a
dyke and my mom was not [ __ ] having
it man she just went after them like my
mom was a fighter like she was just not
my mom had zero fear and i like so i
remember stuff like that but i was like
i was never like worried about my mom
because she was like the strongest
person i knew
so i was never afraid i was afraid for
them because she was just so
so
greek you were like that they didn't
mean it they didn't mean it mom
uh they met a protective dive like a
you know
in water
uh did you know what that word meant
then i mean did you know that it was uh
i know what it meant but i didn't know
yeah i didn't know it was like you know
a bad word you know i mean it was yeah
yeah it was weird a lot a lot of uh like
i just never struck me as an insulting
word i you know saying dyke to me then
was the same thing as saying lesbian
like uh weird yeah just didn't she
probably used it it was part of her
vernacular i think it you know and if it
had just been worked she would have kept
on walking i just don't think she would
have she might have said [ __ ] you
flipped and burned and kept on walking
fire cracking my hair
and she was fighting
wow
you had mentioned like stealing and
stuff was was it that
just your socioeconomic reality was it
just like i want things that these other
kids have you know it's weird man
because i think
it was that but also i think it was just
i was a product of my environment you
know the kids you know where that's what
they they did they didn't have things so
they stole things
you know they i it was not a rare
occasion for us to bombard a corner
store and come out with a
you know a handful of chips and
stupid stuff sodas and like that's kind
of stupid stuff
um yeah we were just yeah just bad inner
city kids
i i remember going to your house and
like the most charming thing was you had
a uh a collection of lunchboxes
and which i had i still have to give you
one i have one i have to give you um but
but what
do you think a lot of that had to do
then you kind of alluded to this
you didn't get all those nice those you
didn't have toys you didn't get like it
wasn't like an abundant christmas for
you
when you were a kid no is there any
sense now that like you have the means
to like
i don't get cool [ __ ] now what is that
yeah i think i've kind of grown out of
that somewhat there are things that yeah
for sure and i think a lot of people
collect things that they couldn't get
when they were kids or things that bring
back memories from when they were kids
totally and so yeah you know i have
those collections of definitely things
that i wanted when i was a kid and
couldn't couldn't have couldn't afford
but i think all that you know the buying
stuff that was ridiculous i i think i
burnt that
when i was uh in wrestling there was a
period of time when i was wrestling when
i was single for the first time ever in
my life
and so i was single i was making
millions of dollars and i could afford
to buy whatever i wanted and so i
blew through my money like i would give
anything i have that money back now
because i just i always i bought all
kinds of stupid stuff i bought a
lamborghini
oh man that's the best answer i was
gonna i was i couldn't come up my
imagination wasn't that
wasn't big enough
i was
you live and you learn i think a lot of
athletes yeah though because you know
there are a lot of pro athletes that
grow up poor now all of a sudden money
is being thrown at them and they just
see an into it it's like it's going to
keep on coming it's going to be there
forever but it's not
so i kind of learned that right hard way
and i went through that and so i i just
live a different life now and it's
probably nice to be able to get you had
mentioned i know you get your are very
still very close with your mom it's
probably nice to be able to do stuff
yeah for her i literally just so i
bought and i really makes me happy to
even say it out loud but i bought my mom
a house it's been a couple years now but
i bought our house in san francisco and
it was it was a nightmare to do it was
one of those things that i the first
time around when i was wrestling when i
was blowing a lot of money like i wish i
had bought my mom a house and i didn't
yeah and i always felt like just such an
[ __ ] for not taking care of my mom
buying her house
and then when it came time to came to
the point where i could afford to buy
our house it's like my mom wanted to
live in this tiny little section of san
francisco and it had to be a victorian
house
and trying to buy like a house in san
francisco is is damn near impossible so
when you narrow it down to like this
tiny little quarter mile section it has
to be this style of house yeah it was
just yeah it took years it took us about
four four years to find her this place
that's really funny why was it why did
she was she so specific
she she just wants what she wants she's
very my mom
my mom is like a really old-school
hippie lesbian in san francisco and
she's very resentful of all you know all
that like the tech money that's pouring
in now
to hear my mom talk about like what
techies with man buns is like the
funniest thing you'll ever hear
i'm so glad i cut mine just bitter and
resentful
that's so funny is she with somebody now
does she no she's been single forever
yeah she's and i don't think she has
that desire anymore i think she's just
kind of yeah old and stuck in her ways
and she's very busy she's
still does uh she's social work she
works with homeless and drug addicts in
san francisco she's just that
consummate do good she just loves people
she wants to help people um well you
definitely got some of that um
that's really cool how she must be proud
of you i mean she must
yeah yeah she's my biggest fan
that's correct does she does she come to
tampa a lot did she come to your film
set so she hates tampa
she hates it
she hates she hates florida in general
she doesn't like being in florida um
and she uh to be honest with you she
doesn't like leaving san francisco all
that much and now she i mean yeah
i like to take her to premieres every
once in a while she's come to a few sets
with me
uh but no i mean for the most part she's
she just rather be in san francisco i
was just talking to a friend of mine um
who's an actress and she was saying how
much more those premieres and everything
there's always an element that of that
those that feel so like absurd and weird
and like what are we doing why
do with the cameras and the red carpet
and now doesn't it now like the idea of
going to a pro like because once in a
while i'll see on instagram like
somebody'll be like from the premiere of
sorry it seems even with everything
that's going on in the world it seems
that much more ridiculous you know the
thought of being
so i don't know i just imagine just
imagine being on a red carpet yeah and
like how [ __ ] weird that would be
yeah no i i can't imagine and i don't
like until things normalize and i
believe they will normalize it'll take a
while but they will but i just can't
imagine just and i don't i'm not all
that comfortable with stuff like that
anyway i'm a little bit i got social
anxiety it just weirds me out
life could be a dream sweetheart
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
because i was so small growing up i
always had a fantasy that like
that people like you and i i'm gonna
generalize incorrectly
have are are
confident uh they they don't feel the
need to assert themselves but but it's
because of how big they are and i always
thought well what what must life be like
in that body and and but but anxiety
just shows that anxiety can come from
and can be in any shape i think a lot of
that perception of people like who look
like me who would exert themselves in a
certain way or impose themselves in a
certain way i think a lot of that [ __ ]
comes from insecurities yeah yeah that's
when i you know that's what i mean when
i got got older when i started becoming
comfortable with myself instead of
trying to pretend that i wasn't insecure
about something i just started owning
the [ __ ] out of it and i became a much
happier person like i when i was younger
you never would have heard me say i have
social anxiety i'm just weirded out by
being here in the social setting i never
would have said that i never would have
admitted huh but when i just started
telling people that's just that's who i
am and be comfortable with it i'm a much
happier person man and was it was that
part of your need to to play up this
persona that wasn't necessarily you i
mean
you're this huge guy you're a wrestler
did you then feel the need to like act
like for sure especially when i was
wrestling yeah because i was
rushed into this environment that was so
cut throat that was so overly
testosterone
and i didn't know how to feel like when
i first saw this actually happened to me
but when i first got to the wwe like i
didn't want to piss anybody off i knew
the way they were looking at me they're
looking at me like it's very competitive
because there's only a few top spots and
i walk through the door and i've already
looked like a mountain of a person and
i've got a charisma when i'm in the ring
um so i already know that this guy's
looking at me like guys [ __ ] this guy's
gonna steal our job so start burying
them and i know that so i'm walking
around on eggshells not trying to piss
anybody off
i'm like being extra gentle with people
in the ring because i don't want anybody
to just say that you know i'm stiffing
them or i'm just doing bad business
and then wow
because you were that much bigger yeah
yeah and i just i just looked apart and
then vince mcmahon comes up to me
uh after a match we you know we used to
after our tv show we'd take a break for
a few days then we'd come back go on the
road but he comes back to me at the end
of the night and he goes what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you
and i said what do you mean he goes
you walk around here you're all nice to
people you're all nice to people in the
ring it's like you know what what's
wrong with you i said well you know i
told him like i don't want to piss
anybody off and he said
are you here to make money are you here
to make friends
he said i want you to do this i want you
to go home over the weekend i want you
to come back next week i want you to
come back full of piss and vanguard act
like you want to be here he said i am
giving you a license to piss people off
i'm giving you a license to do whatever
you want
he said you want to be here or not let
me know when you come back
and so i came back with a you know kind
of that [ __ ] attitude it's like one of
those things where
you get tired
of being on the defensive so much that
you start to become offensive
and when i was forced to be like that
because i was desperate enough that i
this was my last shot in life so it was
desperate
so i was forced to be like that and it
made me so unhappy like i was i
bet because
you know something that goes against
your very nature which is gentle and
kind to to have to be this aggressive
you have to be an [ __ ] yeah that's
cool
that's so how long do you do you
maintain that persona for and does that
inspire you to maybe get out of
wrestling and become an ad well
that and other reasons um but i was i
was in that mode for a good
four years three four years
and it just uh wow
and it was i was successful in
professional wrestling i lost everything
personally but i was uh successful in
wrestling and for the first time in my
my life making money
and which in turn because i was so
miserable i was trying to buy happiness
and it was just right it was like
a horrible place to be i look back on it
now and it's
you know it's i'm just glad i made it
out of it i'm glad i was able to
actually turn myself around also you
know get a second shot how much of that
do you think was you having to maintain
this other persona was there a sense of
confusion when when you'd come home to
your for sure
whoever you're in a relationship with or
your friends or your parents you know
was that hard to be it was horrible and
it you know it's funny because my my
ex-wife and i were very close friends
now um but we've talked about it and she
she would say you know when i came home
she just didn't know who i was anymore
and she was bitter because of it and so
we were just resentful of each other and
our our marriages deteriorated
i had tunnel vision and i was determined
to make the best out of this because it
was the best shot i had left i want to
go back a little to those days um when
you were a kid when when you did then
move back to dc with your dad
uh how was he able to like discipline
you or or who
how were you disciplined um
[Laughter]
was it sports no i was never you know
it's funny because i never realized i
was an athlete until i was a junior in
high school
i didn't i didn't grow up you know i
didn't grow up playing sports i grew up
in the city i grew up on the street i
grew up i grew up breakdancing i was
break dancing well before i was i was uh
into sports organized sports no kidding
yeah can you still do it can you still
good
yeah i got some cardboard i got it oh
dude i actually have a funny funny story
but i know i don't want to take up too
much time but i my mom was at a
wrestling show and she was talking to
the owner owning the company and telling
him that i could break dance
so he got wind of it so he was going to
do this commercial that was based it was
themed around the olympics
and so he thought it would be funny if i
went in and did a little breakdancing
routine as a gymnastics routine so he's
telling me this and i think he's joking
with me i think he's [ __ ] with me all
the
time
so so they actually they pick me up to
go shoot this commercial and i'm still
like you know going along with the joke
and then i get there and i'm starting to
realize
that laughter is not
in the joke anymore like they actually
think that i can still do this i'm like
so when i was brick dancing i was 150
pounds now i'm like
325 pounds
oh my god
so yeah of course you got to spit around
and stuff it on yourself so they threw
some cardboard down and i did the best i
could but it's yeah it's it's it's
online it's oh tell me they used it did
they use it
oh boy oh i'd like to find that i bet
you it's ridiculous it's online it's
like a summerslam commercial it's
absolutely ridiculous
you're a superhero and guardians of the
galaxy do um what is that like what what
is the difference in like let's say with
kids when you meet them um for me it's
like it's everything because i you know
i left i took a chance on myself and
left wrestling
um because i wanted to be an actor and i
remember the first time that somebody
recognized me as an actor and it was uh
it like meant everything because i felt
like it was
it justified me leaving and it really
was a scary thing for me to leave i mean
it was because i was you know well into
my 40s i was uh
really taking a shot in the dark here
but i just i really became obsessed with
acting and i was really unhappy with the
direction the company was going in and
they i think that they were misusing me
and
and so yeah there were some things that
going on were going on that just weren't
really really fair and i so i felt like
i was being taken advantage of what was
it about acting dave and and was that
something that you had ever uh
wrestled with doing before like uh in
in like in high school let's say were
you ever was that something that you
were into you know what's funny man is
so i look back in high school and i was
such an introvert i was so shy and i
remember seeing all the kids from trauma
class
and they were just always you know at
lunch time they were just always very
flamboyant there was always entertaining
putting on a show
and i would we're doing yeah and i was
like so yeah and all of
those kids like i was
if they were just i don't know man they
were just like unicorns to me like i
just
ipad but i so no but couldn't understand
that no performance oh but i loved it i
was envious of them i wanted to be that
because i i grew up really obsessed with
television and obsessed with films
um because they were what were your your
go-to shows well i remember when i was a
kid well i loved all the sitcoms like in
any 70s comic but i also remember yeah
being absolutely obsessed with with
dynasty i remember really that's like
way before your retirement dynasty and
some of those not way before some of the
soap operas you'd be surprised like i i
told you when i i was young and i wasn't
going to school and i would skip school
and i would go over this kid's house
they were older like 15 16. you know
we'd sit around
and watch some soap operas
that's so
funny i did not think you were gonna say
that uh what was it about those shows
were they were they just so different
than your own life was it such an escape
i think so you know i think i just like
the kind of
you know like
overly dramatic storytelling and you
know yeah i remember the first time like
in the 70s and
godfather had appeared godfather they
showed god's father on tv like over a
few nights i think
but i remember like bugging my mom about
godfather asking her all these questions
about the godfather and she just
like just didn't know it didn't care
but i remember being so curious about
you know godfather just
you know but you know all through the
70s 70s 80s i mean great movie heiress i
mean so
you know i i were you an alien were you
a fan of alien
yeah absolutely of aliens but even
earlier than that like i remember seeing
rocky in the theater and jaws and
theaters and star wars in the theaters
and being just smoking abandoned
theaters yeah oh that when you grew up
you came of age during like yeah
i think that's like later 70s like
that's when i really remember like going
to the movies and really falling in love
with the movies and just it was escapism
it was escapism from my you know kind of
shitty life so then then did wrestling
become a more accessible route to to
escape that life how did wrestling
happen it was not something that i
planned on doing i you know i always
tell people this is not a glamorous
answer but so i was closing in on 30 and
i was still bouncing i was you know
living paycheck to paycheck and i was
broke
and there was one particular christmas
where i had to go and borrow money to
buy my kids christmas presents and i was
humiliated i was
and i made a conscious effort i was like
i gotta i gotta make a change i gotta do
something and i stumbled upon this
tryout for professional wrestling
and so i pursued it because i i needed
to make some money you know i was broken
there wasn't much i was qualified to do
i didn't have an education i dropped out
of high school wow dave i didn't know
that did you then did you ever get your
diploma i didn't i was on my own um
since i was 17. my dad kicked me out of
the house when i was uh
going into my senior year of high school
i was right after my wow
and so were you like oh then [ __ ] school
then i i don't i just want to start
making money i tried to go for a while
because i really wanted to i really
wanted a high school diploma i really
wanted to finish high school nobody
wants to drop out i didn't want to drop
out
but it got to the point where it just
wasn't you know
making money was more important i needed
to make money to live and i was doing
you know not
not good things
um
so i you know i just left and nobody was
telling me i had to go to school and i
felt like at that time i just wanted to
have a few bucks in my pocket and i was
young and stupid and
so that's what i did and dave did you
you never considered
just cons because of your size i i'm
shocked that you never considered
playing foot football
in dc that that was not an option i did
i tried to play football a couple years
in high school but i to be honest the
honest answer to that is i hated the
other [ __ ] on the team there was
always like a bunch of there was always
a bunch of [ __ ] on the team and i
didn't like being around them meat heads
total yeah your stereotypical meatheads
i didn't want to be around exactly they
were [ __ ] cliches i didn't like them
i couldn't relate to them so i just felt
like an outcast i didn't want to be
there drama wasn't an option because
those kids like you said they were like
unicorns to you they were so foreign and
and you just didn't feel like you'd fit
in with it i didn't and i just never
could have in a million years i've
gotten up on this in front of people and
performed i was
like so i was so shy and so introverted
i was i was that hot kid i was weird i
was like
i had issues like reading i was you know
i had dyslexia i have 80d i was kind of
all over the place and i didn't know
what was going on at the time i just
thought it was stupid and my dad was
telling me i was stupid but i learned i
learned good verbally if somebody taught
me something
sit down yeah the book was like a
nightmare for me so you know in class
you have to read out loud there's always
your turn to read out like i would get
in the back of the class and i would
hide i would be in the back hiding wow
he's still calling me
it was probably hard for you to hide
well that time it wasn't as hard
yeah okay
you know one point i just stopped going
i stopped going to certain classes and i
just stopped going to school at all
because i just felt like such an outcast
so if you had this performance anxiety
so crippling that you couldn't even
imagine getting up there how then isn't
there an element of that in wrestling
how did how were you able to overcome
that to then get in the ring and be this
be this character that's weird i didn't
have as when i
performed physically i didn't struggle
with it because i just i was confident
in my athleticism
i i could do that part when i had to
actually get on the microphone and speak
it was absolutely a nightmare for me um
and at the time when i first started
they were writing all my speeches for me
and i was trying to memorize this and it
was just horrible and i was trying to
like perform just it was such a
nightmare they write your speeches for i
didn't know that well they did they did
it first and then as i came into my own
and i started to really uh become
successful i started to get over with
the crowd and i started to become like a
fan favorite i got to the point where
i actually discovered that if you're
making money for the company you can
basically do whatever the [ __ ] you want
so
i got that point where i said i'm not
i'm not saying this give me bullet
points i'll go out and i'll have a
conversation with the audience
so that was when i became more
comfortable it was still a struggle but
i definitely it was more comfortable for
me i also found that
i can deal with being in front of crowds
easier or talking to people or public
speaking if i wear hats if i wear
glasses if i have some type of pacifier
or something to hide behind that you
know i can kind of get lost in my my own
so a lot of times you'll be so
interested talking in a wrestling ring
and i will be wearing it i'll be wearing
glasses i will just be kind of hiding
you know myself but i
became a very conversational thing
rather than a speech that i was giving
right i should point out that dave is
now wearing like yellow tinted
uh sunglasses which i i often don't i i
don't even register as it being
different because that's just i've
that's every time i've seen you that's
you've worn things kind of like that
yeah well usually when i go out in
public or
you know do things like that go and talk
shoes i usually wear some type of tented
glass and a lot of people don't really
realize why i'm doing it but it's just
because it's just i feel more
comfortable for something
so most of my glasses are tinted and i
don't
normally like go out in public and
speak publicly without tinted glasses
how do you feel about uh you were i cut
you off you were going to say the
difference between um the in the fans
from a fan's
world from let me start again from from
uh the perspective of having fans right
what is the difference between the
wrestling fans and and
now you have marvel you have kids who
probably get excited to see you
i don't know if there's a difference
between
fans but there's a difference to me
personally because of what i what i left
what i you know what i sought after and
it means more it means it means more
because yeah acting was such a
challenging thing for me but also
just taking that shot on my uh you know
on myself and taking that risk yeah and
i risk a lot my future the future of my
family i risked it to just take this
shot on myself and dive into and you're
in your 40s my 40s you're in your 40s
and what was the moment what was it that
was like was there like the straw that
broke the camel's back was there like a
you know an epiphany moment that you had
where you were like i'm going to pursue
this and then what was that first it was
a it was a few different moments um
for one the you know the wrestling
business really really changed they
started to take more of a pg direction
um and i just didn't fit the bill
anymore i did things a certain way i did
things a very old school way
i just i you know look at me i don't
look like the all-american
right that they're trying to now market
to you know
yeah
and also i
sorry dave what's the old-school way
like in terms of wrestling is it like
what would that mean it was so if you
watch wrestling 15 20 years ago was much
more violent everything was violent and
it was bloody and it was rough around
the edges and it was raunchy
and that was the business i knew because
you know i
i felt like people in order for people
to really kind of suspend their
disbelief and really getting sucked into
this there has to be an element of
violence
and that was kind of the way i was
raised in this business and then it was
all stripped away from me they said well
you can't do this anymore you can't do
that anymore you can't say these things
anymore i was like wow i just don't even
know what this business is anymore
um were you like
were you playing a good guy did you have
a what was your persona kind of more
aggressive you said
i became that i was very aggressive um
yeah and i was uh yeah i was typically a
bad guy i was more comfortable in the
bad guy role and it's you know the odd
thing is i think people like me in that
role
yeah so it's just something i was more
comfortable with um
i think we always want to play somebody
that we're not necessarily totally
yeah yeah
oh yeah but anyway you must have gotten
injured a lot too
yeah i had throughout my career i had
about um 13 surgeries 13 like major
surgery there were repairs
holy god but i don't you know it's weird
because now i i was pretty good about
taking care of myself i was also very
good about like i saw guys get addicted
to drugs and i saw what it did to them
uh painkillers i saw guys who were just
existing on painkillers and i was never
i was never one to go down that route
so i think i i
i did myself a huge favor by not going
down that route just kind of yeah advil
every once in a while just talking it
out sucking it up and that's one thing
that's great about professional
wrestling is even if you are you're
hurting you can always because it is
entertainment you can find creative ways
to work around something you just have
to be able to you have to have people
that are willing to work with you but
sometimes you just got to speak up and
not try to be that tough guy and say you
know just right and say i just i need to
take it easy tonight
um and i mean you struck me as someone
very disciplined uh you mentioned not
doing drugs and just kind of uh
having other ways to deal with it uh
have you been you i know you're v you're
a vegan
i'm not i actually eat uh
fish i eat fish in poultry i eat fish oh
that's right okay yeah
okay well then so i my my ex-wife
my third ex-wife
[Laughter]
i i i feel so awful so i feel like i've
just turned into just one big cliche
get out of here are you kidding you're
not the the opposite of that david my my
third ex-wife it sounds awful but
there's actually
there's a lot of reasons why i
divorced three times
yeah um and good good reasons but anyway
she she was a vegan so you know she
lived a vegan lifestyle which made it
you know very easy for me to fall into
it
oh
sure yeah and and uh
oh you do okay all right um i was gonna
say how disciplined that is but you're
still disciplined about what you eat
right you're very pretty i have just
have certain roles but i you know i
really believe
like this kind of a rule of thumb for
life in general is just everything in
moderation
yeah you know i don't you know like
except for working out
yeah even that in moderation like uh so
i've learned how to gauge it i think
i've heard learned how to like i don't
need to go out all out all the time i
think consistency more than anything but
also like
i find like i find other outlets like
working out doesn't necessarily have to
mean lifting weights um you know for me
like lately i looked on foot drills i
don't know for some reason i love
putting the ladder down and doing foot
drills okay it's like it's funny it's
just a new form of stimulation and also
a new form of just exerting energy
so it's it's still it's it's therapeutic
for me and also it's crazy i'm obsessed
now with the goddamn speed bags oh yeah
it's like you ever play with one of
those fidgets
fidget spinner yeah yeah the fidget
spinner so for anxiety and stuff so the
meathead version of that is the
speedback oh okay it helps to deal with
um it's it's the repetition it's like i
think so it's just it's complete focus
you can't lose focus on this thing you
completely so you're just completing the
rhythm of it get yourself one at home
it'll be the best thing you ever bought
okay i have one at home in my closet
that i hit yeah all day long five hours
stressing a little anxiety i go in my
closet
hitting this thing for a couple minutes
and i feel better are there types of
roles that you wish you could play um
that your your physical
stature doesn't allow like like
everything about changing your body to
to open yourself up into two different
roles yeah you know i i do and i've
tried that you know it's weird i tried
that
oddly enough i tried that before i did
the first guardians i uh this like
starvation diet and i stopped lifting
weights and i was still like 260 pounds
and it's just if you look at me back
then you can see that i'm not as
muscular but at the same time just like
i have a i have a massive head i have
really broad shoulders yeah i have long
arms and big hands and i'm just a bigger
human being so even when i when i feel
like when i trim down i just look
funnier
like i feel like like this kind of all
somewhat close together but when i when
i get smaller like my head's still the
same size and i just looked up
well
did they want you to because that
character i would imagine part of it is
like did they want you to be big and
muscular did they say anything about
like you're being you being too big for
guardians no is that just you
yeah so i well i had kind of a game plan
on the first one i just didn't have much
time to work with and it was so i was so
heavily made up honestly i could have
been i could have been in worship and
you probably wouldn't have noticed
because my makeup process was very
different uh is that bodybuilding or is
there latex yeah the first one was like
sheets of latex
wow the process for guardians 2 and all
the avengers was completely different
completely different they were just
little transfers so most of it is
actually me
not so much on the first guardians and
you can if you look closer you can you
really see the difference
but so i'm probably a lot easier to just
do the transfers right
so much easier the problem they were so
the the they were about the transfer
furs were available for the first film
the problem was they weren't sure how to
get them off fast enough so i could you
know well i wouldn't be there 24 hours a
day because it took forever
you know it took a long time
so
they found that if they sat me in a
sauna for like 20 to 30 minutes they
just start to melt off and then they
come in and wipe them off so now i spent
it's like an hour and a half for makeup
uh application and like an hour for
removal oh that'll look bad
and the first one was like it was like
four to six hours for application
wow holy
hour and a half for removal you don't
want to wrestle anymore um the business
is changing how do you then make that
leap i know other people have done it
but
what's the first thing and like what do
you say to your family and your agent
and how do you how do you do that
so well at that time it was just me and
my buddy jonathan he's my manager he's
been with me throughout uh wrestling and
so i i
caught the bug man in a bad way for
acting and it really it was because i
found out how bad i was wasn't
i went and i did this job as a favor to
a friend
and i thought that it was supposed to be
fine to be easy i'm you know i've been
doing television for years now i'll be
all right yeah and i just sat there and
i was just humiliated i just felt so
everything that came out of my mouth i
was cringing inside and i just want to
really curl up in a ball and hide and i
felt
so embarrassed so i wanted you know i
wanted to get better
and uh well wait sorry dave i'm that's
that's that's so interesting to me you
as you were doing it you felt like you
didn't believe what you were saying oh
my god
from the character i was so
and it didn't hit me until i was there
trying to perform it and i was just
stuck i was just stopped there just
humiliated yeah i just felt like i was
so embarrassed about how bad of an actor
i was
what was that job it was called um the
wrong side of town it was okay starring
another professional wrestler uh anyway
so i just want i wanted to get better
and i started yeah
started you know trying to pursue jobs
within the company and they just weren't
offering them to me
i said well it's just you know
it's the fair thing you know to be to do
would be to you know if you're not going
to let me do these this within the
companies i should be able to go outside
the company and you know audition for
jobs because i really want to pursue act
and they said absolutely not you're our
intellectual property you'll stay here
wow shows and i said well then i'm going
to let my contract run out and i'm
leaving
and they said no you're not and i said
watch me
wow well about a year later i i left and
i left and started pursuing
so during that year um you know you have
another you have that you're remaining
on your contract during that year are
you doing anything to
to pursue acting in other ways are you
are you practicing are you taking
classes yeah no not at all i just i
couldn't my schedule when i was there
like i never survived it it was i mean
it was a tough grind it's not it is not
an easy company to work for you pull
your weight and you earn every dollar
you make uh but when i left i left and i
that was the first thing i did i moved
out to la and i started working with an
acting coach
and for you a few months later i was off
to like getting auditions when i could
which was wasn't easy i think three
times or three years i worked three
times until and i was desperate and i
was going to move out to la to audition
more
and i got uh i got guardians and i just
oh that so that was the first big thing
so how did how did that happen
that was james gunn just so auditioning
yeah so for years i didn't have an agent
my um old agent um who's very different
i love him death his name is brett and
orange brings with gersch
and for years he turned me down actually
three times
and tried to get with gersch
and he kept turning me down and he said
i just you know i just don't know what
to do with you i don't know what to do
because i wanted to be an actor i didn't
want to do like you know crappy kind of
straight to dvd movies that everybody
wanted to put me in i wanted to be like
an actor like a real yeah
and uh
so
and finally i just kept running into him
everywhere because i was close friends
with another guy he represented
and i ran up to him everyone he finally
calls my manager one day and he goes you
know i really like dave i'd really like
to help him i just don't know how
and so anyway so he got one of these
that's almost more insulting
like it's like that's how what yeah
that's how beyond help you are like he's
the nicest guy i i'd like to but he's i
don't know how
i never it's funny because he i never
let him live that down
but it was just he really did i like i
learned later on he just didn't know
what where i fit in he didn't know what
yeah what to send me out for what to
pitch me for and he also wasn't aware
that like i really was taking acting
seriously i would tell him but when he
as he started to see me perform he could
see that i was really serious about
acting
and so it became easier throughout the
years because he knew what i wanted he
got it and he saw what i was willing to
do what i could do
um but then at that time he just so he
got one to the drax audition
and he represented me for like a week
but he got whatever
and he calls me up and i swear to god he
goes no i don't want you to get your
hopes up
that's great
but
i got you this audition and i really had
to fight hard to get it for you so can
you fly out here and take this audition
it was for drax
and so i went in and i met with sarah
fenn and i did my audition and she
uh she was like couldn't have been any
sweeter and she and she calls me later
that day and she says uh hey can you
come back and uh read for the director
tomorrow and i was meant to fly out so
i'm supposed to fly out she said would
you mind staying real like you to come
read for him and that was the first time
i met james
and so from then it was just like a
series of auditions and chemistry tests
and it was like i think like two months
two three months later when i actually
got my part so i was like waiting and
stressing waiting stressing and you go
back to florida then in between that
yeah yeah because i looked before i was
there full time and i'd fly out when i
had to do a chemistry test or an
audition or whatever it took and
that's why yeah
yeah you probably can't talk a lot about
like the future of that
role in that franchise but
what can you say about the next few
things that you're going to be doing
marvel wise marvel watch well we'll
start the things i can say yeah
definitely we will definitely start
filming guardians um unless something
really catastrophic happens we'll start
filming it i believe later next year
okay cool but there will be a guardian
story okay that's great and james is
directed everybody signed up james is
directing very cool i'm ready to go we
just need our slot to stay open and i'm
really looking forward to wrapping this
up this up man like it's cool it's like
this podcast or the
no not this pocket we're almost
this journey with guardians because it
started with me i mean it started there
i mean it really started my
it was weird man once that that
that movie was released i didn't have to
go searching for jobs anymore they were
amazing it was when people started to
have faith in me you know what's weird
is
my
little small role in blade runner
opened up just as many doors i think
because people saw me in a different
light as well
well that's
yeah i know i did i mean black people
should want i mean i first of all loved
that movie um
and both roles require a lot of
introspection and they're
they're a lot more complex that's the
thing about drax is that um he has an
inner life that is a lot more uh complex
than i think people give it credit for
because there is something
he's the heavy and he's monosyllabic and
all that but but he's very thoughtful
and and um and with few lines that's
very difficult to do and
and and then like you're tested again
when you're in stuber yeah so
super to me was the first time i saw you
um play like
really high stakes in in a comedy but
but what i loved about it is that you're
not
which you're not treating it like a
comedy um
in the sense that a lot of times now i
think with like modern comedy
performances you see that
the actors are aware it's a comedy and
they're and they're playing the jokes
you were so grounded and that it takes
confidence to be really grounded in that
part and play the intentions and
i thought you were you're so good dave i
texted you about it and i i wouldn't be
repeating it if i didn't know that you
had been so insecure in a couple years
earlier
horrible yeah i was even while we were
filming i was just so unsure of myself
because really yeah i just didn't you
know it's a new role for me it was a new
you know adventure and you know and a
comedy and uh so i did internally i
struggled but thankfully
i had camille like he was just i loved
that kid and we just got along so well
we just really connected so he made it
very he was very reassuring i'm very
proud of that movie i was crushed that
we didn't do better because it's weird
we got such great
feedback from fans but the critics hated
us
and also we we got sandwiched between
like blockbuster films we couldn't have
i couldn't have had like a worse release
date
that's right
it was like the lion king and spiderman
thanks a lot they were like sandwiched
between i think uh
oh toy story had just been out like the
week before i think well then you think
about like there's got to be somebody
complaining about guardians of the
galaxy going up against guardians and
they're like oh we have to go
you know so
for sure
[Music]
what is the term dream chaser where did
that come from because you you end a lot
of your instagrams with that yeah it
seems to be a mantra of yours yeah i
don't know where i originally
came up with that as my moniker but i
got it tattooed on my arm like 15 years
ago like forever ago
and it's just i've always kind of lived
my life by that like i there's things
that i became obsessed with and
fascinated with and they were just
dreams and i just chased them like i
chased them down like i hunted them down
yeah and i'm just i'm just that guy and
i just so i always use i try to inspire
people that way and i would say you know
if you if you're that person who can
like make a living doing something that
you love i mean that's a very rare thing
that but that's right now is that
something that everybody should pursue
you should always try to get through you
know making a living that doing what you
love i agree whether it's accounting or
teaching or being a wrestler uh maybe
not a wrestler uh a movie star
guardians well you know what's cool is
like now i'm imagining all of the young
kids um looking up to you i mean how
cool is that that must be yeah it's
crazy
that's really cool um what is your most
commonly used emoji dave oh god probably
the scrunchy face like i always like uh
so i always think of homer simpson going
down
like
yeah oh yeah with the kind of eyes like
this like yeah
yeah
okay um
if you could be a professional athlete
what sport would you play
oh probably basketball
oh yes welcome i'm always
like basketball is just jumping up just
slamming the balls it's like so you know
it's exciting plus you know people i
don't think football i don't you know i
i just think basketball is a little more
clamorous and i like to be like that guy
were you a uh would it be a the bullets
were you a washington
bullets fan um i was and still am they
turned in the wizards i still go on
twitter test and wear my bullets jerseys
but yeah
really
minute bowl it wasn't minou bowl on that
but no
wow that's awesome yeah uh
and do you have any good suggestions for
the washington i know you're not you're
not a huge football fan then
um your buddies must come over on sunday
those guys some of them must be football
fans and watch the game i have a few but
i'm not uh most of my guys are
most of them are like fight fans and
which is me like so boxing is my
favorite sport
oh and so if you did one mma you were in
one mma fight yeah which you won
what made you why did you only do it
once well i pretty much spent every time
i had left going into training for this
um
so it was a really bad experience to
fight itself because um i lost my
opponent the week before the fight um
so i had a last-minute opportunity to
pick a new opponent
and there was not very good options so i
went with the guy who was had like 40
something pro fights he was just uh he
was younger than me but still looked out
of shape and older than me
and you know and i figured you know okay
it's whatever it's my first fight i'm
gonna clean the floor with this guy but
he actually clocked me in the first like
first second of the fight and the reason
he did is because i froze
like it's a weird experience man because
i think i was ready and i am i'm i'm
pretty good at martial arts
but when that door that cage door shut i
was like
what the hell am i doing here
oh i'm getting panicky yeah i'm not
having a panic attack it just took me
like it took me a minute to get into the
fight i was just like frozen and i
couldn't explain why i was confident i
was in shape
but i literally was just frozen for
about a minute
i snapped out of it and i snapped out of
it because i got pissed off so when i
got them as well because you're getting
hit in the face and that's people who
don't know that's they're they're barely
wearing gloves i mean he was like a big
he was big husky 300 pounder and he's
just like he had nothing to lose so he
just came directly at me just clocked me
with the first punch he threw and it's
just like does that send you back does
that send you down it just knocks it
might not be silly because it just uh
it just he caught me right on the chin
and it just oh yeah just had cobwebs for
like a minute or so before he did
something that really pissed me off and
i was like oh i'm just going to beat his
ass and i just so i just
like i wish i had to do it over again
but i also wish that like my opponent
that i originally had so funny he was
also making his pro debut so it's going
to be two guys making their pro debuts
oh and he got arrested the week before
for having a
loaded handgun in his car so it's
probably at home that's probably a good
thing that i didn't fight this guy
yeah well was he was he also know had
you been known at that point as a
wrestler
i had and i really oh wow so i really
only because i was you know my 40s like
i had no business fighting but i i did
it because i loved i loved it so much
and i really really wanted to go through
the experience
and so uh yeah i did it and then after
after the fight i had to ask my question
myself questions like
i spent all this money getting ready for
this fight i get nothing from it didn't
make a dime for you know from itself wow
am i in my 40s do i have a career at
professional fighting absolutely not do
i want do i even want to be like a
champion do i aspire to be a champion of
fighting i don't i just i just love the
sport so i could do this get my head
bashed in make no money or i could
pursue what i really love which is
acting and so that's why
i pursued acting
not get your head back yeah i'm not
getting my but i still train i train
regularly i have my own gym yeah
training with guys and i love it still
love to this day not any less but i just
it's not it's not who i am as a person i
think you have to be there has to be
something wrong with you to to be a
professional fighter i say that yeah
but you have to have some kind of hate
built up in you to be i
i would agree with that i would never
agree with that publicly if there were
an mma fighter around here i would say
dave i think that's a really offensive
thing to say um what what were you was
there a point when you were can you even
recall like when you say like well i
just said i beat his ass like can you
recall or some of those earlier fights
as a bouncer
can you recall like
ever having a moment of uh
is it blind is it is it like um does
something overtake you or are you able
to think rationally like oh i hit him
too hard or like oh i hope he's okay or
you know you know it's weird because i
don't uh i don't have a panic mode
i don't it's not something that i have
i'm always uh even killed person
and i do remember that fight very well i
remember that he knocked the piss out of
me i remember thinking very clearly that
it can take me a couple seconds to snap
out i was actually
when he came in for like he so he he
clocked me and as i was backing up he
clocked me again and i was against the
cage and i said something really smart
ass to him
so
i said you hit pretty hard for a fat guy
oh my god
so this is this is kind of the inside
story of that because
i said that to him
and as i was trying to you know clear my
head
there was a point a point in
point in this fight where i looked over
at my corner and they were all freaked
out i saw that they were freaked out oh
they were looking at me like oh my god
what the what the hell is going on and i
smiled you're just riling him up did you
say
you smiled at them so i smiled at my
team and so they all i could see them
relieved
and so that the arrest broke us apart uh
he backed up and i could see that this
guy was laughing
which pissed me off and so i had a game
plan i was going to try to stand with
this guy because i figured he's fat and
boxing was not my strong point but i i
worked on it so much that i wanted to
show it off
but i knew my strong point was wrestling
and i knew my strong point was jiu jitsu
well after he pissed me off i was like
[ __ ] the game plan i'm just going to
take him down i'm going to beat his ass
so i just
but after the fight was over they
stopped with your legs you took them
down down like in a more wrestling way
yeah yeah just a double yeah a doubling
yeah it's just so like i was an amateur
wrestler as well and so i took a double
leg i knew it was my strength and i
pounded them and they stopped the fight
and after the fight i said but i hit
harder
and so he rolled over on his back and he
kicked me in the nuts
oh my god after the whistle after it was
over yeah he rolled over oh my god he
kicked it i probably deserved it
no one deserves a nut kick i mean some
people he totally are you
i was wearing a cup yeah yeah you're
required
so anyway so it's funny things so we had
a bit of an argument the funny thing is
later that night at the after party the
[ __ ] guy came up to me and he's like
sitting in my lap and we're having a
drink together i'm holding this guy like
a big baby in my lap and it's just like
all loves a big fat baby
oh my god that's great but it was good
he was a good dude man he just he took
the fight on last minute notice he had
nothing to lose took it we wow you know
we kissed him a made-up after that at
the at the party and that's kind of well
that's cool yeah um uh if you could have
one i don't know how to pivot to this if
you could have oh by the way the the
washington football team do you have any
suggestions for what they should rename
the team i oh man i was just thinking
about you know what uh
i had a name that was in my
because you're a big nationals fan you
go to the games you've thrown out
pitches i thought i thought a cool name
would be um the natives
you know why we thought about that my
brother we're talking about that yeah
the natives so not getting completely
away from
yeah
the logos and everything because i love
the logos i think the logo is totally
honorable i think that the the name
redskins are a little you know
disrespectful to you yeah probably i
couldn't live without the name i don't
have any you know emotional attachment
to anything but i thought the natives
and you know what
you got to watch nationals
yeah logos because i love the logo
me too i i was a fan growing up and it
was such a it's i mean they have such a
great history that organization that
team yeah john i remember joe theismann
and john i remember watching those games
back then i i loved the gibbs era um so
you're right that's a great
okay i hope they're
listening um if you could have one snack
food for the rest of your life what
would it be
i'm gonna go sweet because i think
that's just in the mood i'm in and i'm
gonna say just okay cupcakes
i'm just picturing you because i when i
think of snack i picture like a thing
that you can just pop i'm just picturing
[Laughter]
what's your cupcake flavor what's your
go-to
cupcake flavor i'm
i'm the guy
so i can't eat i'm the guy i can't eat
one cupcake i've got to eat like seven
cupcakes
yeah
and i took just whatever's in there
whatever is calling to me but i'm also
like when i was a little kid i loved
like strawberry cakes like the
strawberry oh yeah so i probably leaned
towards something like that something
fruity flavored
was your mom into nutrition was she like
or was it like oh god you were having
pop-tarts yeah we were having whatever
we could afford my mom yeah cooked
everything in a pot because she wanted
leftovers everything that would last us
yeah for a while
uh so yeah it was always big stews or
you know that type of food
greek specific was she very greedy
no my mom's funny man my mom so
my grandmother my father's mother taught
my mother how to cook to cook filipino
food
wow so we grew up more on that and we
also grew up on things like you know
like a lot of rice because rice was
always cheap it was easy yeah yeah like
we used to eat rice with everything
which is rice with butter rice with soy
sauce like
yeah uh what is your favorite movie of
all do you have a favorite movie or or
one
maybe one in quarantine that's brought
you like comfort to watch
no it's always going to be a toss-up of
a few movies and it is i think my
my favorite movies are always from that
again like the late 70s era 70s yeah
yeah jaws and star wars josh all those
godfathers i mean that you know is there
somebody that director you've worked
with i mean you got to work with ridley
scott and james we talked about is there
a director um
that you'd really like to like really
you know i really want to work with man
and i've reached out to him uh but i
really want to work with fukuoka
and there's oh yeah i usually so i
like my career is like they're like it's
like a puzzle there's certain pieces of
the puzzle that and i think that i love
the way [ __ ] fuqua makes people look fun
makes people look sexy and i i want
fukuoka to make me look sexy
did you hear that antoine no one's been
able to accomplish that but i think
antoine fuqua as talented as he is could
actually make me look sexy tonight
i don't know why you said no one's good
do that i need that piece of the puzzle
okay well he's probably listening
uh he for people don't know he's a great
director yeah
i love him yeah he was able to make
denzel washington look
how good is this guy
yeah how do you do that um if if you had
to live somewhere else uh besides your
mom's favorite tampa
where would it be well in the states
obviously it would be my hometown of dc
it would be yeah if it was in the states
it would be dc or san francisco um okay
but if it was outside the states it
would be london i love london oh yeah
if you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive uh whom you've
never met or maybe met so superficially
that you that you'd want to have a
dinner with uh
who would it be like throughout history
too oh god so mark twain would
definitely be one oh yeah you know what
you know i'd like to um
sit down and talk with us uh
don't murray
yeah i've heard mixed stories about bill
yeah i've heard
they're all entertaining though right
they're all entertaining but it just
seems like you'd just be like the most
interesting conversation ever i
agree i agree what i love about them is
that they're uh they're all these
sightings and now of course they're
videos because everyone has a video
camera of him just like he'll pop behind
a bar and stuff here i think he lives in
south carolina uh and he'll just pop
behind a local bar and he'll just start
serving drinks and he just seems like a
real like good time charlie
and then uh
and probably um i know it's gonna sound
hot but probably malcolm x
i mean i'd like to sit down and have a
conversation with them and then sound
out at all that's a great lineup bill
murray god bill murray malcolm x and
another these are just popping off the
top of my head but i think mark now he's
i think malcolm x would always be on
that list i'm yeah deeply fascinated
with malcolm x who's your favorite
muppet
muppet oh man
did you grow up with the muppets dave in
oh absolutely yeah absolutely i'm just
trying you know
i'm gonna have to go with oscar
oh no
no wait why what what what about oscar
you're just such a crouch you're like
such a great yeah all right let me i
i don't know if this will put things in
perspective so i have i have
a dog his name's frankie he's pitbull
and i i actually lost frankie the
divorce um which is i'm heartbroken over
but yeah he was such a grouchy dog like
he would sit out on my back porch and
literally just wait for somebody to walk
by so he could just bark at him bark at
him and then as soon as he walked by
he'd go back and sit on the porch again
and just wait for somebody
my dog was just so grouchy that just he
was i just he was so committed to being
crouchy i just thought
it was so entertaining so i think i just
entered
that funny though but but i'm sure your
dog and i have a dog similar to that my
dog max is like a real lover loves
snuggling up and getting like pet but
but yeah any other dog goes by
he had asked for the grouch energy
yeah if you had to be one age for the
rest of your life what would you pick
physically that is uh and knowing what
you know now having your mind now oh you
could just be that age physically
probably 40 yeah or 40 oh yeah yeah four
years just when i became comfortable
with myself
yeah
so um
if you could be reincarnated as a
non-human animal what would you pick
probably a lion yeah
you know what
people have said line before i forget
who said it recently and i'm like oh
that's a stretch
that's not a stretch for you i can see
you
being alive being a lion um would you
rather be called unattractive or unfunny
um i'd rather be called unfunny
i admire your honesty
yeah why what do you need why
that's very honest
um
which which golden girl do you most
identify with dorothy blanche rose or
sophia
oh oh man
i don't know if i if you were one if you
were to play that one of those parts if
i was gonna play one i'd play blanche oh
okay yeah that's just most fun come on
oh yeah she's the most fun yeah but it's
funny i just pictured you
in that environment with yes
as blanche i just picture i had a very
strong visual of you as blanche it was
very fun
um
mcclanahan really funny uh
uh do you prefer dogs or cats i think i
know this dogs all day long
yeah
the two you have now seem great they're
so sweet yeah i really looked out like
we found each other
it was a perfect time i really needed
them and they they needed me too it was
like it was that was meant to be
they were rescued in that area yeah yeah
because it was weird because they were
littermates
and they were turned into a shell they
were just turned into a shelter somebody
he just didn't want him anymore he
wasn't taken care of they were very
badly neglected um wow they weren't
matching when i when i got them but so
when they had never been a part in the
shelter split them up immediately and
the local pit bull organization found
out about it so just adopted them out
without a home just took them out to
keep them together and started searching
for them for them and i had just lost my
dogs in the divorce
um so uh i took them and it just i mean
that's just they are
they make my life complete man they're
actually i'm the sole of my house
i love that dave um we're almost done uh
chocolate candy or fruity candy do you
pick oh chocolate yeah okay
uh and are you a skittles person do you
like skittles no no i don't i don't like
the sugary stuff now
yeah
um and dave do you ever think about like
legacy or how
how you'd like to be remembered um both
as an actor but also i mean i think
maybe more as a person
do you ever think about that kind of
stuff
i will yeah my i want my legacy to be
that uh
that it was a storyteller you know a
storyteller through performance through
film through producer films i hope to
one day direct a film uh i was gonna say
yeah hopefully direct multiple films but
you know not bigger films not
blockbuster films i like indie films i
like indie dramas
um
so i i think just you know that's i i
just love storytelling man it's just
yeah it's changed my life it's inspired
me and i'd like to leave that legacy if
i can just tell stories that inspire
people man i'd like to be that guy
well i i i just think you're uh i think
you're an inspirational person and i
think like you it's
it's just been so such a pleasure
getting to know you a little bit yeah
i'm glad we got to do this yeah likewise
this was fun yeah
[Music]
well well that
yeah he sounds if i had never seen him
and i just heard that interview yeah
yeah i would assume he's barrel chest
well well that happened yes there's like
a there's a cavern yes he just sounds
like a big he does
and he really is i mean i
i didn't want to stress that any more
than i did in the in the
well but
did i yeah but i understand why it bears
i think it's fascinating how large and
at the same time gentle
yeah it's a really fascinating it is
a combination it is there were there
were animated characters like that in my
life i know that only in so far as like
who who george who is that um i'm going
to make him sound dave is not stupid
obviously you just heard him but um i'm
thinking i know you're talking yeah you
were my friend george is that marv from
the marvel martians frank yeah and who's
marvin the martian kind of dominates and
um
so you're marvin the martial like this
in this scenario i guess so
but um he is
yeah yeah it's it's so interesting and i
was so curious
to get to know him better back then and
he um
he was i couldn't say this to him but it
was interesting when uh he answered the
door because he wasn't expecting me
he's a big fan
literally a big fan it was funny to see
him kind of like
and there was a childlike quality to him
that i recognized right away and he yes
he wanted to show off his stuff and
you know oh look i got his friends these
he introduced them all and they were all
very like
mass in fact there were some that were
bigger than him wow his they're all
wrestlers um yeah they were all in like
the working out world they were all like
some guys like that i think have to
working out is such a huge part of their
lives because they literally just spent
i mean this is like duh but they spend
so much time doing it they have to
maintain their right so socially they
yeah develop connections with people he
was in the gym i think he told me
twice a day for a couple hours he gets
excited talking about different types of
workouts yeah
yeah he both loves it and needs it which
i found really interesting that he has
an outlet for yeah because like he says
this about himself i'm not saying it's
about him but he's [ __ ] up don't be
nervous
that he's [ __ ] up and he needs that
working out essentially saved him from
from doing something potentially he says
as he laughs killing someone
appropriately i thought that he is
a good role model for
you know kids yeah being
but in so many ways like it's not just
oh he's he's cool and i know big and
muscular and
and um and benevolent
as a person but also that he struggled
so much as a person so i to me like any
he's such a perfect candidate to be a
role model too i know that he overcame
so much and and it wasn't as though he
because this happens a lot with people
of his size i think not a lot but i
think this is a more common story that
you're that big you're blessed with that
kind of physical ability and um and so
that just carries you through high
school you become
a
some sort of athlete
but he didn't even discover that until
much later you know that wasn't even
like it's not like he got some college
scholarship well he had this closet uh
obsession with
films and yeah
so that was that was crazy the dynasty
he used to skip school and i was like
bad boy friends would like to sit around
and watch dynasties
that was the best i know i did not
expect i understand and that he's uh i i
i just find him so charming i find that
juxtaposition so
likable and endearing isn't he doesn't
he have like
such an endearing charm to him uh
something like that and that and again
like um
and i don't mean this in a condescending
way i mean in the best way
i think children are
in in many ways better than adults i
think he has like a real child like
quality which made it all the more
[ __ ] up that vince mcmahon i know
that that's a beautiful that was yeah so
like it's kind to call it manipulative
yeah yeah yeah you like kind of forced
his personality to be shittier
yeah and it and it ended up really
affecting his personal life oh god yeah
that's that's really
abusive it's abusive there's something
um i guess we should save the rest of
this for the mcmahon episode
oh [ __ ] that guy what a i mean to do
that to a soul like such a gentleman the
fact that his instinct was to be like i
don't want to step on totals and i want
to be like nice to people and to like
and you know what i i bet that happens a
lot i bet it happens a lot in sports
like you gotta get out there be mean but
maybe to play devil's advocate to play
mcmahon advocate
maybe there was a method to that madness
and in order for dave to have become a
successful wrestler he kind of had to
adopt that persona otherwise maybe he
might not have made money yeah and he
might not have been able to train right
you're right right then it's like well
then take issue with all of wrestling
right as a wow
i don't know i i i don't know nothing
about it but he does pull the left i
mean he's the guy he's the
uh he pulls the strings of professional
oh yeah so he's the wizard yes so i mean
it's true what do you take issue with
who do you who do you take issues right
um
not wrestling fans no
it's this massive world that we don't
know about and so when people say like
when you hear statistics about how
popular it is it's it's so hard to
believe but then
because i just have no frame of
reference i have no um
i i'm not just so unaware of it well you
know i feel a little bit that way about
downton abbey oh yes in a very different
way yes but when i see downton abbey
when i think downton abbey because i've
never seen an episode i think like oh
miss pringles yeah in the studies yeah
and i just think like setting up the
dumb waiter again i'm like no thanks i
know it's great and people love it i
just have no zero burn bridges in the
drawing room oh have scandalous yeah
it's all this like and
people have tried to explain it to me
like well
and oh the rest of our family is like
don't understand yeah just just watch an
episode yeah togo togo was like oh so
many people obsessed with that i'm like
i don't understand why
because
they're always like well it's about
class you know it's like the servant
class and the uh and like yeah yeah i
don't want to see the upper class [ __ ]
that's what it is as far as i'm
concerned
and like maybe
maybe there's intrigue that i wonder if
people are gonna get mad at this it's
funny the crossover between
bautista wrestling fans and downton
abbey fanatics downtown downton that
fannies what do you what do they call
themselves downton
i don't know
fabulous downtown downtown east
it's not downtown no no no downtown
downton these downton east
i know i wonder if that's ever been um
mentioned in the same
sentence dave bautista
wrestling fans and maybe to be like how
different they are but in this
but they're similar in a way it's a
world that i'm in a huge world huge that
i'm yeah but not just downton abbey all
of those types of period yeah that era
there's so many i mean they the
the crown i mean and they make so
many movies people knows people love it
when you ask them
what golden girl he identified as and he
he was like
oh um
i don't i don't i don't know if i uh
he like but he's so nice yeah i want to
be like you know i don't hate on the
question yeah i don't identify as a
ghost hacker
so he was like well i guess um he's so
nice i would want to play play yeah he
couldn't even yeah but as in his defense
of all the guests we've ever had
he is the farthest from any a golden
girl so just physically oh yeah well
yeah yeah but now i'm imagining um
him remaking don't shoot don't who do
you think he would stop for my mom yes
yeah with the stella getting mrs uh who
would he be he would be
you know probably
um
sophia
oh
yeah i don't think he's a dorothy no i
guess not dorothy i was gonna say
dorothy but um maybe a little rose
a little rose
and a little rose and a little dorothy i
think because he has pre there's
something pragmatic about him um
it's hard to see him as any now because
i'm picturing i'm having a general about
it yeah and he's just oh
so massive like
i mean i can't stress this enough when i
when i opened the door it was it's like
you are in his shadow right away and it
takes you back it's that kind of size
that like especially when you see him
the way i did for the first time which
is right at the door right it's at
somebody's door because it's one thing
when he came to set you know it's like
oh he's behind the monitor he's like at
a distance or he's you see him
approaching and it's like whoa you have
time to adjust to his size but it's when
it's like a door open and he's like boom
there god you know we should do now yeah
uh maybe we should should we read a real
letter oh okay cool letter from caitlyn
b
caitlin boylan
remember boiling soda it was nice that
you protected her anonymity for two
seconds
but does it matter is it are you not i
don't know okay i feel like if they're
writing in and they're writing their
names exactly then they're okay with it
yeah i think we should operate under
that consumption well then now i can say
uh until you get sued
i can say boylan i wonder if she has
anything to do with the boiling soda
anyway subject giving birth on justin's
b day and 30 rock and bud light seltzer
would you rather it's cool
well greetings justin christian and crew
over there at life is short this year of
course has notably been one of the most
abysmal we have all experienced thus far
but one amazing thing has come out of it
and that was giving birth to my daughter
jovi oh jovi cool name
jovi i knew joby he did j-o-b-y oh see
that's tricky because i know scottish
people call
jobbies when they poop it's that's right
it's a scottish room for pooping
she was born on june 2nd
justin's b day i almost said bj
just
justin's b day which i learned during
your nick kroll interview that's right
because nick is like a couple days later
june 5th june 5th good memory and we
have been pretty much learning to become
parents in isolation ever since wow
we are lucky to live in northern
california so we can enjoy the outdoors
most of the time and host a friend or
two in our backyard to try and maintain
some normalcy however it has been sad to
not have friends hold our daughter due
to advice from our doctor it's also been
said because my entire family is on the
east coast and will likely not meet her
until well past her first birthday wow
sigh she says but you know i gotta say
uh having just experienced nephews it's
hard to meet an infant yeah
yeah because there's no it's they don't
like meeting requires both sides to know
what's happening right right it's it's
like meeting a turtle
where it's it's just like it's exactly
like meeting a turtle it's well it's
like
you know it's not you're not getting i
know i agree so in other words so
hopefully that'll be comforting my
husband unfortunately cannot work from
home so my daughter and i are home alone
most days listening to your pod as well
as dax's pod have gotten me through
these long days thank you for your
hilarious banter and thoughtful
interviews well thank you katelyn that's
really cool to hear so i have a would
you rather that i actually acquired from
30 rock
as i've been re-watching it during the
pandemic
i've just slightly revised it would you
rather okay would you rather have to
start every sentence for the rest of
your life with oracle's with the urkel's
catchphrase did i do that
every sentence
that's
oh my god would you have to say it like
urkel she doesn't say just the oracle
sketch race did i do that did i do that
can you pass the camera yeah did i do
that i'm running out um to the store for
a minute let me know if you need
anything
did i do that i will so far it doesn't
sound that bad no we're also saying very
simple things can you imagine did i do
that we're also saying very simple
things did i do that can you imagine
saying something
was every sentence or every thought
every sentence okay that or be attached
to donald trump for one year be attached
oh like um conjoined twins
you would be attached side but side to
side
so you would have your own organ systems
and
penises ha ha if donald trump is too
political to talk about you can swap him
out for mel gibson oh yeah much better
so much less political yeah
less dicey uh they're both really spicy
to talk about but well i see but it
doesn't matter that's what i was gonna
say yeah to me it's just the idea of
being attached to someone you don't know
exactly there was this similar would you
rather that we have yes like would you
rather take a country drive with donald
trump yeah once a year and that
hypothetical i didn't consider politics
either either because it's i mean this
would be harder to escape politics
because you'd have to be a he is a
political figure so you'd have to be
around whatever him all the time yeah i
guess so and he's the president so he
would take precedence it's not like if
you're conjoined to the president you
can't do your own [ __ ] see for me it's
not about
him though or what he does or his job
it's it's more just
having to be practicality
yeah but but you would have to consider
him
as a person then i mean in terms of what
his habits are and
you know but i don't i don't exactly
know what his habits are though i know
what he's like as a president you know
he golfs a lot he's a public figure but
he see he wouldn't golf that year if you
were attached to him yeah he would no he
would i bet he'd do whatever he he'd try
to keep as much normalcy if i was
attached to his hip he wouldn't be able
to golf he wouldn't be able to do
anything really you couldn't you could
engulf he'd golf on one side right way
so it would be like change it would be a
lost year that's what it would be it'd
be a lost year for both of us and it
might be kind of interesting to talk to
him i guess
but for like
yeah yeah a year is a long time think
about a year i would rather start every
sentence with um but that's the rest of
your life did i do that i know but i
would get used to it and i would i would
start um being a little bit more
discerning in my words
i wouldn't talk as much as i do not that
i talk a lot now but yeah i would be
more careful and i would write more i
think i would send more messages that's
true and you'd get you'd say and it's
not again it's not about donald trump or
mel gibson no i just like anybody i
wouldn't want to be stuck to anybody for
you even somebody that you really
admired a month is a different story
yeah that's true that's a good point you
know what now i'm thinking about it uh
practically and i you would get so good
at saying it would just become uh wrote
to say did i do that
did i do that i i'm thinking about uh
driving your vacation it would be
annoying did i do that maybe to the
caribbean or did i do that it would be
very confusing to strangers
but again it would be hard to get to
know people it would but don't you feel
like i know enough people you know
that's how i feel it's like
yeah i got good i got people yeah um
okay my second would you rather is a
little less complex but hopefully still
tickles your fancy
would you rather pee bud light seltzer
but it burns every time you go
or would you rather vomit jesus vomit
bud light seltzer every time you hear
music
i don't know why it has to be bud light
seltzer because you're not re-ingesting
it right oh who cares what um
wait what happened so when you pee it
stings burns every time burns or you
vomit blood like cetera every time you
hear music uh yeah i agree i don't think
it matters i love music
i
i just not listen to music i would say
um
i would say it depends what the burn
feels like i've never thankfully i've
been lucky i've never experienced a
burning sensation when i urinate well
you haven't it's also yeah you know
yeah um but i've never experienced that
feeling
but when i think like i'm thinking of
like a real burn you've mitigated the
wrist
std
uh
the thought of
burning every time i urinate
seems pretty terrible and i urinate a
lot more than i listen to music so i
think i would rather um
yeah your reading is
urinating is just a bigger part of my
life than i love you you can't not do it
yeah whereas you can avoid music but if
you're like does that mean if you're in
a store during like christmas shopping
and i know uh
your christmas song comes on you start
throwing up wear ear muffs ear plugs
okay
where are those things that they give to
kids children of musicians at festivals
yes but if it was just a minor stinging
sensation
i would i would do that probably get
used to that it just depends on how bad
the burn felt you know you could ask
your uh conjoined twin donald trump if
you get used to that kind of sensation
that's a good point burning when you pee
um yeah you know and what i would do is
because what i really miss uh when it
comes to music is going to like a faster
i'm thinking specifically of trans picos
like music festival festival like that
that christian i go to every year um and
so what i would do is just before the
day of music began obviously i would
just know that i was going to throw up i
was going to puke um and i do that and
then i listen to music as as much music
as i could throwing up is horrible
though
i know i talked about that before i i
don't know if you could enjoy the music
knowing that you would just be throwing
up the whole time oh no no see i thought
you you threw up every time you hear
music so it's like
you start the beginning of the concert
and you throw up oh
i think it's every bar of music oh oh
okay well that's a different story then
you pee we need a little more
clarification yeah caitlyn next okay
right back in uh and if you guys want to
write in uh like caitlyn it's uh life is
short at wondering.com is that the end
of the letter no oh sorry that was uh it
broke protocol premature yeah uh i just
saw like an opening you know i'm like
and you seized it yeah
running back i guess any running back
who sees an opening
who's that running back oh the
professional one
yeah
thank you again for keeping me company
katie oh she says katie she's caitlin in
the beginning katie c-a-i-t-i katie p.s
i'm not famous or anything uh just a
third grade teacher
you have to qualify it like that but i
wanted to say that my favorite emoji is
the upside down smiley face i feel so
surprised that no one has said that
said they use it as often as i do i feel
like it sums up so many things and is
often the perfect response to most
people end of letter what does it mean
oh she didn't say no
she's got her right back she's got her
up katie we need another from you i need
some clarification on the on the
urinating and um yeah can you please
someone explain this upside down smile
you said she says many ways you can use
it
name three yeah i'd love that three
examples because i've gotten it before
you've talked about it i've talked about
it in different contexts and like kind
of like in one context i remember being
this one i got really curious about it
it was like a cheeky flirty context yes
you've said that one
but whoever said that isn't listening
sorry to shame you because that was a
great letter otherwise a great letter
yeah and and and jovi great name young
jovi we want you to write back and uh
think of joey on a scale of one to ten
how bad is my p burn
yeah and uh the upside down smiling face
and um
what's uh jovi like uh i'll be fine is
jovi short for something yeah jovial
anyway thanks to everyone who is writing
in because uh we we love reading the
letters even the ones we don't read on
the air and thank you to our
large and kind
and uh hearted big-hearted
benevolent guest oh yeah he's benevolent
um this is a very easy prediction to
make but he will continue to be a huge
movie star for a very long time
dave bautista yeah yeah that's a pretty
easy prediction right about the like the
uh odds in vegas i know yeah
well you know why because there's so
many things he can do in that world it's
not and now knowing that he's a good
dramatic actor and comedic actor it's
like plus he can always do an action
movie right because he's [ __ ] like
great at that and he's nice to people
and people are going to want to work
with exactly exactly all those stories
you hear about people who like become
maniacs he's not going to do that never
going to do that because he knows better
because he he struggled too much yep
just an impressive person and uh really
grateful to know him grateful he did the
show and grateful to you guys for
listening as always we'll talk to you
next week
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's produced and co-hosted by you
christian long and it's produced by
megan monica senior producer is michelle
miche lans audio engineer is sergio
enriquez the executive producers on this
one are on this one
marshall louis and also and also ernan
lopez for a company called wondering bye
[Music]
if this was more accurate the job should
be
the lion should be like a navy seal or
something some arm someone that that
requires and he can't go on missions
right
um this scarecrow should be an
accountant or a professor and he's a
classmate no he'd never become a
professor exactly
or he should want to be an accountant
maybe he's stuck being a scarecrow right
you know but he should he should aspire
to be exactly he loves numbers he loves
yeah he loves the academic life and
stuff
and the tin man should be what he is an
axe man
who is man who aspires to be
wait what is the tin man
he he's uh he's like a woodsman
he cussed entries yeah i think so
but he should aspire to be something
else he should aspire to be how does he
make a living
you should work you should want to work
for unicef what are you saying he like
sells wood
uh i don't think he sells wood how does
he make a living
i don't know
i don't know i mean i didn't even make a
living what
i don't know if you need to make a
living in oz
yeah it's make-believe
yeah i mean scarecrow just has to scare
away
uh well dorothy's parents were oh but
they don't live in alice
it's the land of ice
you